>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE INTERESTED
IN THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY.
LOOK AROUND.
HOW DOES IT LOOK?
IS IT CLEANER AND MORE ORDERLY
OR LESS?
THAT'S THE SUBJECT WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSSED ON FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S MAYBE MORE MEANINGFUL THAN
IT IS STUPID NUMBERS FROM WALL
STREET AND WASHINGTON.
FOR THE FIRST EPISODE OF TUCKER
CARLSON ORIGIN ON FOX NATION.
RESIDENTS OF CHICAGO SAID
PROSECUTORS STOPPED ENFORCING
THE LAW.
WE HAVE PROOF.
OUTSIDE OF THE LOOP AND THE
AFFLUENT AREAS, IT'S HORRIFYING.
PEOPLE WALKING DOWN THE STREET
NAKED AND PEOPLE SHOT IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT AND PEOPLE LIVING ON
THE STREET.
WE REPORTED ON THE DRUG USE
THROUGHOUT SAN FRANCISCO.
WE FILM DUG DEALERS SELLING
HEROIN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
A BUSINESS OWNER HAD BEEN BITTEN
BY VAGRANTS MANY TIMES.
IT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE OF BAD
LAWS.
THAT ALLOW VAGRANTS TO TAKE OVER
PUBLIC CITIES.
IT'S NOT JUST SAN FRANCISCO.
IN VENICE BEACH, CALIFORNIA, IN
LOS ANGELES IT'S OVERRUN BY
PEOPLE LIVING OUTSIDE.
>> THESE ARE HOMES.
GUNS, KNIVES, FIRES.
DRUG USE.
>> YOU DON'T REALIZE WHAT YOU
ARE LIVING IN THE MIDDLE OF
UNTIL YOU SEE A VIDEO.
WAIT A MINUTE, THAT'S WHERE I
LIVE.
>> THERE WAS A CLEAN UP TODAY.
>> HOW OFTEN DO THEY DO THIS?
>> THE FIRST ONE IN 6 MONTHS.
THIS IS NOT HUMANE.
>> IF I WAS A COUNCILMAN I WOULD
BE DOWN HERE RIGHT NOW SAYING
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THIS?
>> THE CITY COUNCIL ALLOWED THEM
NOT TO HAVE A ROCK BOTTOM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S VENICE,
CALIFORNIA.
A BEAUTIFUL PLACE WITH CANINALS.
NOW IT'S A DISASTER.
CANALS -- AND ONE CITY
COUNCILMAN IN L.A. IS TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORSE ON THE WESTSIDE OF
THE CITY.
HE WANTS HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS AT
THE AIRPORT.
THIS IS THE END OF LOS ANGELES
OF COURSE.
SOME PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT AND
THEY HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
A PETITION TO STOP THIS PLAN
WAS STARTED BY THIS MAN JOINING
US.
WHAT DROVE YOU TO THIS PLACE?
>> THANKS, FOR HAVING ME ON.
I WILL MENTION WHY I ALMOST
DIDN'T DO.
I AM NOT A PROFESSIONAL PETITION
MAKER.
I WOKE UP ABOUT A MONTH AGO AND
CHECKED MY EMAIL AT 6 O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING.
THE FIRST THING I SAW WAY MOTION
THAT A COUNCILMAN WAS PUTTING
FORTH TO PUT HOMELESS VILLAGES
AT THE PUBLIC BEACHES AND PARK.
I KNOW THE NAME BONIN.
I AM NOT IN POLITICS.
I WENT TO ON CHANGE.ORG.
I DIDN'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT.
I PUT THIS PETITION ON THERE
HOPING TO GET 200 PEOPLE.
BY THE END OF THE DAY MY WIFE
AND KIDS WERE SIG THERE.
-- SITTING THERE.
3,000 AND THE NEXT DAY 5,000.
EVERY DAY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THIS MANY
PEOPLE -- IT'S NOT THAT I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT.
IT'S ASTOUNDING WE ARE ABLE TO
CREATE A PLACE THAT THIS MANY
PEOPLE CAN VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
I ALMOST DIDN'T DO IT BECAUSE MY
HESITANCY OH WE WILL BE SHAMED.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> I FEEL LIKE I HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO MY FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY TO SAY THIS DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
YOU ARE PUTTING THIS AT PUBLIC
BEACHES AND PARKS.
I DON'T GET IT.
I PUT MY HAT IN THE RING AND WE
STILL CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
LOGIC IS BEHIND BRINGING THE
HOMELESS TO THE BEACHES.
TO SOME OF THE MOST VALUABLE
LAND IN THE COUNTRY WHEN THERE
IS TONS OF OPEN LAND IN
CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
HOMELESS PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK I AM NOT BEING
COMPASSIONATE.
I AM SAYING, WAIT A SECOND.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
WHY ARE WE GOING TO WASTE OUR
TIME LOOKING INTO THE
FEASIBILITY OF PUTTING 100 TENTS
IN A PARKING LOT AT THE BEACH
WHERE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE COME FROM THE INNER
CITIES AND FROM ALL OVER L.A. TO
ENJOY THAT SPACE.
FIND A PLACE THAT IS MORE
APPROPRIATE THAT WILL BE
CHEAPER.
WE CAN CREATE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT FOR THEM AND DRUG
ADDICTION SUPPORT, IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Tucker: YOUR OPPOSITION THERE
IS NOTHING PARTISAN ABOUT IT.
YOU ARE A HUSBAND, FATHER AND
RESIDENT AND TAXPAYER.
WE PUT YOUR PETITION UP ON OUR
FACEBOOK PAGE.
YOU ARE DOING A GREAT TH